from a juvenile where my clothes had
holes in them and my afro is picky to
the nighties moschino and versace no
laces in our cheese new millennium
[Music]
is
that's my man
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
are you mad i need no problem oh my god
i'm going crazy brother you know what
matt's gonna do man's gonna jump out his
liver matt's gonna clean the mixer man's
gonna drink him yeah
i've showed them before i'm going to
show every single one of you man's bro
but hurry up bro come here hold up but
come here what are you mad
are you mad well it's for you step by
step guide how to pray brother okay yeah
hey what are you guys saying you're
moving moist yeah no i'm gonna shake all
of you up bro i don't need no one how's
it spread bruh i brought you why is this
gonna be familiar what do you mean
familiar what are you talking about
oh my gosh what the hell are you doing
here
nisha what are you doing here bruh nice
guy you know earn a bit on the side
didn't it you know what i'm saying and i
thought i don't know what you're saying
brother the mcdonald's what are you
going to say here get me baby come on
come on
yeah i'll be the event only the salon
then
yeah come on what's that we pray
that bro let's pray all right man's
going to do this
we call him bro
you know come on come on now it's been a
bit funny these days recording yeah well
come on
let's play him looks sick still come on
all right guys make the road straight
bro we're trying to make the road
for my lord like a soldier hydrogenome
rugged made for my lord like a soldier